what is the most beautiful
mysterious or surprising idea in the
biology of humans
or viruses that you've ever come across
in your work
sorry for the overly philosophical
question
wow well that's a great question you
know i love the pathogenesis of viruses
and uh one of the things that i've
worked on
a lot is trying to understand how
viruses interact with each other and
so pre all this covid stuff
it was uh i was really really dedicated
to understanding
uh how uh how viruses
impact other pathogens so how if
somebody gets an
infection with one thing or a vaccine
does it either benefit or harm you from
other things that
appear to be unrelated to in the
to most people and so one
one system which is highly detrimental
to humans but what i think is just
immensely fascinating is measles
and uh measles gets into a kid's body
the immune system picks it up and
essentially grabs the virus
and does exactly what it's supposed to
do which is to take this virus and bring
it into the immune system so the immune
system can learn from it
can develop an immune response to it but
instead measles
plays a trick it gets into the immune
system
serves almost as a trojan horse and
instead of getting
eaten by these by these cells it just
takes them over
and it ends up proliferating in the very
cells that were supposed to
kill it uh and it just distributes
throughout the entire body gets into the
bone marrow kills off
children's immune memories and so it
essentially
what i've found and what my research has
found is that this one virus was
responsible for as much as half of all
of the infectious disease deaths in kids
before we started vaccinating against it
because it was just wiping out
children's immune memories to all
different pathogens which is
you know i think just astounding it's
just amazing to
watch it spread throughout bodies we've
done the studies in monkeys and and you
can watch it just
destroy and obliterate people's immune
memories in the same way that
you know some parasite might destroy
somebody's brain and
it's is that a evolutionary just
coincidence
or is there some kind of advantage to
this kind of interactivity
between pathogens i think in that sense
it's
just coincidence it probably is a it's a
good way for measles to
it's a good way for measles to
essentially be able to survive
long enough to replicate in the body it
just replicates in the cells that are
meant to destroy it so
it's uh it's utilizing our immune cells
for its own replication
but in so doing it's destroying the
memories of all the other
the other immunological memories so but
there are other viruses so a different
system is influenza and
uh flu predisposes to severe bacterial
infections
and that i think is another coincidence
but i
but i also think that there are that
there are some evolutionary benefits
that bacteria may hijack and sort of
piggyback on viral infections viruses
can
they just grow so much quicker than
bacteria they replicate faster and so
there's the system with viruses with flu
and
and bacteria where the influenza has
these proteins that cleave certain
receptors and the bacteria want to
cleave those same receptors i want to
cleave the same molecules that
gave entrance to those receptors so
instead the bacteria
found out like hey you know we could
just piggyback on these viruses
they'll do it a hundred or a thousand
times faster than we can
and so then they just piggyback on and
they let flu
cleave all these stylic acids and then
the bacteria just glom on and
in the wake of it so there's all
different interactions between pathogens
that
are just remarkable
you